[Music]
thank you everybody for coming super
excited about this discussion excited to
present with Daniel and Bhaskar from CBS
a very cool story how they migrated off
of terror data into bigquery and GCP
before we we get into that awesome story
Bhaskar has given me three minutes of
permission to talk about some of the
cool things coming out of bigquery so
does everybody know what bigquery is is
he show hands I can kinda see I'm not
gonna really go into this okay the only
the only thing I like to call out is
that it's server that's right it's a
fully managed in service environment to
do your you know your big data analysis
in again like one of the cool things
that I love about big queries we want to
take care of all that operational
annoying stuff and so that you guys can
focus on running your queries and
running your analysis and we take it you
know if that's what that server listing
enables you guys to do so we can do that
heavy lifting so you guys can do all the
fun stuff and get insights out of your
data so bigquery has been around for a
while and it's a very powerful tool it's
a very powerful platform and what we've
been weakened in the past is helping our
customers migrate into bigquery and so
you know we like to call these the
on-ramp so we have very weak on ramps
until now and just recently if you guys
have been following some of the
announcements we just launched a data
warehouse migration service and so that
includes three different services one
ter data migration which is awesome
we'll talk about that a little bit for
the next CBS hopefully makes it a little
easier and a little faster for them to
migrate into bigquery so that's in beta
if you go to the console and you click
on the data transfer service you can
actually migrate schema and data pretty
seamlessly into bigquery we also
launched a redshift migration service
which is an alpha so if you guys want to
reach out to your customer service or
your partner or your account executive
on we can whitelist you for that and
then s3 so you can if you have data in
AWS you can put it on park' files or
Avro files in the s3
we can automatically load those into
bigquery so super excited about the
service and again hopefully you know if
Daniel bhaskar did this again it would
be a little bit easier for them so with
that I'm supposed to get off the stage
now but I really excited introduce you
to Bhaskar and take it away hello
everyone from CBS Interactive you know I
have been and I will come into the stage
in few minutes but I'll first to go over
some of the high-level details of the
migration and these are the topics that
we are going to cover today trust me
this is not a sales pitch
I just want to give you a high-level
idea of CBS Interactive what we do to
give you some sense of scale and
background on CBS I we are the largest
premium content company and ranked at
number seven per comScore report after
YouTube we are Google's largest ad
partner and within the verticals we
serve our brands our leaders and number
one in all categories outside of sports
where we trial only behind ESPN and CBS
I is a well positioned to be the network
of the future and we have reach across
TV entertainment news sports and more
and more local news live streaming huge
growth for us in connected TV space and
OTD platforms before going into the
details of today's topic have a quick
question for the audience how many of
you are actually planning to migrate to
the cloud I don't know if I can see
everyone but I could see some hands
rising so it's good so first I will take
you I'll show you the platform that we
have before the migration and at a high
level you know this is our
infrastructure footprint and if you look
at it we have 27 node teradata cluster
with a one parappa 120 tape terabytes
disk space and 22 Hadoop nodes of one
petabyte disk space and also we have six
CPU informatica server we have
automation engine
tableau which is our reporting bi
reporting and visualization - and we
have data products wherein we create
custom dashboards which cannot be done
through tableau so this is a footprint
at a high level and if you look at the
data flow the data we acquired through
internal and external api's and also
internal databases we acquire into HDFS
and also NFS and process through hive
and
Tara data and we also copy most recent
data from hive Tutera date almost daily
basis this is mainly to because of the
database constraints we have size
constraints on terabyte Tara data and
also if you look at tableau and other
data product applications we have the
choice of querying either high or Tara
data so there's a flexibility our
analysts have and if you look at some of
the challenges that we are having scale
if you are familiar with database
appliances it is not easy to increase
the size without going through a lot of
effort it requires a lot of money
resources and it's not easy and same
thing with Hadoop you know we have to
plan a lot and if you look at SLS in the
past we had frequent delays in SLA and
sometimes we were delayed by 4 to 6
hours and for us data is critical
because you know ours is a media company
and you know we are not short of major
events we have measured events
throughout the year starting in January
all the way to December and we start
with the CES and then March Madness
Superbowl lot of news events and a lot
of other all access original launches
and a lot of other events so there are a
lot of problems with the SLA so there's
one of the challenge and sequel you know
I'm sure you know some of you also might
have in in your companies
we have few users who could bring down
database to its knees and of course you
know it is not my intention
even everybody writes inefficient
sequels at times even I did too
so whenever those inefficient sequels
are going into Teradata
the performance is going down and then
we do the backups almost every week and
whenever the backups are happening the
performance is degraded and every Monday
we have always constantly has to monitor
you know how the reports are coming
along because we have seen most of the
delays on Mondays and also the
concurrent users if the number of users
are increased on the system it is
typical with some of these appliance
databases that the database performance
will go down so these are some of the
challenges that we were having and right
around that time there was a
company-wide cloud-first initiative
which helped us to actually start
thinking about cloud migration and also
CBS and Google are good partners we have
been using Google's products for example
we have been using B of P which is dot
for publishers and also G suite so it
was a natural evolution for us and it
was a right fit to start looking at
Google cloud and that is how we started
our migration so let us see you know how
we actually read the migration we
considered few options for going into
bigquery so option number one it is
migrated only data to bigquery an option
number two migrated and third platform
got meaning infrastructure processes
data everything to cloud however this
option number two you know sounds good
but with the given time and resources we
thought that it is not possible to do it
so we looked at a middle ground which is
option number three so now let us look
at you know what that option three is
and what are some of the details of
option three so migrate data to cloud
meaning wherever the data is processed
we have to have the data in the cloud
that way all the users will have access
to one single database for their
analysis and second big data so we
thought that by processing the big data
in the cloud will help us a lot because
that is where we have most of the
challenges and we tackled that first and
when I say big data mainly around
clickstream data which is you know the
web traffic and atom pollution data and
also there were no technical constraints
for us not to migrate the processes into
the cloud so it made us for making the
decision while we did that we also
changed the data structures for these
big data sets and that helped us a lot
with performance and of course in a we
did this in consultation with a task
force which was formed by inviting some
of the key stakeholders from our
businesses and that worked out pretty
good and I'll give you some more details
later on and also if you look at the
dimension of processing it is not while
by query is very good and high
performance database we cannot do
traditional or the DMS like we do with
traditional databases
whereas informatica process that we had
had a lot of inserts updates deletes on
a daily basis so we couldn't do that so
we looked at informatica replacement at
that time however we couldn't find a
good replacement and also with the given
time and resources we decided okay we
are going to keep informatica for now
on-premise
however copy all the process data to the
cloud because ultimately the goal is to
have all the data in the cloud we also
decided to keep all the Hadoop jobs on
Thomas however we made a simple change
by writing the output files not only to
Hadoop but also to GCS and this give us
a leverage to reduce the time of
migration also at the time of
decommissioning Hadoop
it it made made it easy for
data product applications we decided to
migrate the application code first while
keeping the Kara data on premise because
while the code is in the cloud they were
the applications were talking to the
database on the premise so we did that
because we wanted to make simultaneous
progress with you know multiple I would
say a lanes
you know project so those are the
additions we took and likewise you know
the BI reporting servers we kept them on
premise these also purely because of
time otherwise there is no technical
reason so that also we kept on contra
miss and the next one I'll show you the
timeline now how all this migration took
place so we started March 2017 there's
when we started planning and then
started looking at all the new tools and
technologies because we are going into a
new platform brand new platform and we
need to evaluate you know what is out
there and what we need to do with all
the new tools so it took us about six
months and by August 2017 we're actually
ready to actually start migrating or
start working on the actual code so from
August through January we we have
migrated the code that is required for
the first business unit so by January
2018
our first bu is ready to go live and as
you can see at the bottom it took us
about eleven months for the first site
to go live which is amazing and then by
May we are live with all the business
units in bigquery
all of this took fifteen months and then
if you look at the July 2018 that is
when we shut down the Tara data so we
kept running the Tara data between July
between May and July for about two
months
just as a fallback you know in case you
know if anybody has any doubt or
anything they can always go back but in
July you know we started shutting down
the Tara data and between July and
December we converted Hadoop jobs and
then by
December we were able to shut down
Hadoop so all this has happened like or
22 months and as you can see we have
supported three different data platforms
over an extended period of time which is
not easy and also we had to migrate this
data over many many brands where the
priorities are different for each
business unit and also we did all this
with a team of eight dedicated engineers
with some help from other engineers
across the company and it was a great
team effort and we have an excellent
stakeholders who have helped us with a
lot of testing early on and what all it
is a great team effort so now I'm going
to hand out to Dan who will talk to you
about some of the technical details of
the migration dan okay so I'll cover the
Google cloud architecture that replaced
the on-premise systems that we're
retiring the migration strategies for
our big data acquisition jobs our ETL
jobs in our historical data and the
technical challenges that we encountered
during the project so the scope of the
project was to retire Hadoop entire data
and move our data products to declawed
so who Dupin Authority are going to be
gone so what do we replace them with so
for the big data acquisition scripts
they used to write to the Hadoop
distributed file system because we
needed a large distributed file system
to store and on so we replaced that on
GC on the GCB platform with ana patching
the fi cluster that we set up on the
Google compute engine and it would write
its data that GCS I'll cover these
systems in more detail soon for our big
data transformation jobs we were
place the Hadoop MapReduce jobs with
Apache beam on Google data flow for hive
and Paula and Terra data they all got
replaced with bigquery
so our informatica jobs were writing to
Terra data so to replace Tara data we
wrote the results to an on-prem Postgres
database and then we used the Apache
knife I cluster on GCE to copy the data
daily to bigquery for our big data
acquisition jobs as I said we replaced
it with an Apache knife I cluster on GCE
and we installed those as dr. containers
on Google's container optimized OS so
the way it works is that the vendor
places their data files on GCS every
hour and we have processes a workflow
running continuously in a patching the
eye-fi listing new files that appear in
the bucket fetching them doing
pre-processing on them which is mainly
decompressing the data and writing it
onto our own GCS buckets for later
processes to work on and the knife I
workflows also subscribe to a pub sub
topic that accepts commands for
reacquiring data in case there are
operational issues our operators can
issue commands to the knife i clustered
reacquired data so for our ETL that was
running as Hadoop MapReduce jobs as
Python programs so we wanted to reuse a
lot of the transformation functions that
we had on the on-prem systems so we made
a decision to migrate to the Apache beam
Python SDK
and run it on the Google data flow
service so in order to do so we created
agent machines on Google compute engine
that has our automation engine agent
it's also running on Google container
optimized OS so the agent is running as
a service in a docker container and
accepts batch job commands from our
on-prem automation engine server and
those batch jobs launch a container for
each batch job from application images
installed on the agent machine in each
of those batch jobs our dataflow client
jobs that issue commands to Google data
flow service to run batch jobs to
process the data so it's taking the data
that knife I had placed on GCS
transforming it you know inputting the
results in GCS so part of our Google
double-click add data transformations is
denormalizing the data looking up 20
fields from 9 tables we found it was
hard to write and maintain in Python in
data flow so but it was easy to write it
as bigquery queries just having 9 left
outer joins in the query and in our
testing to find that it ran really
efficiently in bigquery so that's what
we're using in production today and in
the future we are preferring elt and
bigquery in most cases since it's easier
to write and maintain so another part of
the project is that we needed to get
years of data on the order of hundreds
of terabytes from on-prem to GCSE in
bigquery so for data that's only entire
data we first copied the data to Hadoop
once the data is on HDFS we can use
Google's cloud storage connector and we
installed that on our on Prem Hadoop
cluster to copy their data in parallel
up to GCS
so we installed our GCS our Google
credential file service account files on
our client machines and then our on Prem
Hadoop cluster could write the data the
GCS and it was extremely fast if we
wanted to we could have copied all of
our data in just a few days also at that
time bigquery did not support Park a
file format for data loads to bigquery
so we created a system that we could
write configuration files of hive
queries that for each table that we
needed to convert and those hive queries
would convert the data types and write
avro files on HDFS and we wrote
automation workflows to do daily jobs to
write these Avro files on HDFS use the
Hadoop this CP command to copy and
parallel the GCS making use of Google's
cloud storage connector and running the
BQ load commands to get it into bigquery
so for informatica we needed to replace
all the workflows that target Terra data
since Terra data will be retired so we
couldn't target bigquery directly
because all of those jobs are written as
transactional inserts and ups and
updates so what we decided to do is we
duplicated the workflows and targeted
them to an on-prem Postgres sequel
database it was on Prem because of
limitations in the database drivers we
had that had write latency issues
so since informatica was on Prem the
post curse sequel database also had to
be on from so to get it into bigquery we
used our knife I cluster on Google
compute engine we created workflows that
accepted commands from Google pub/sub
those commands saying to copy tables
from the on Prem Postgres sequel
database to bigquery and we added those
table copy jobs to our daily schedules
in our automation engine
we also created global flags in our
automation engine for Teradata
retirement and added preconditions to
our Teradata workflows on those flags so
with just by changing one flag we can
turn on and off all of those terror data
workflows so now I'll cover some of the
technical challenges we encountered
during the migration project so as I
explained there using this complicated
system of getting the data into Postgres
and then copying it once a day using our
knife I cluster so we'd like to simplify
that in the future so we've written a
library for a reusable code for getting
slowly changing dimension data directly
into bigquery the way the system works
is that new and updated records are
appended to log tables in bigquery and
the sources could either be daily batch
jobs that append records from recent
days or it could be real time streaming
jobs that append to log tables and both
sources are subject to duplicates so we
wrote this template templatized
bigquery sequel that reads from the log
tables and creates new versions of
slowly changing dimension tables two
types of those tables type one for
writing the current version of the
record to the destination table and type
two which is writing deduplicated
history records for each key to the
destination table so the main parameters
for this library is what's the source
log table that were reading from what
are the what's the key for this table
and what are the fields that identify
the ordering or record versions for that
key and from that we create an order by
clause with the most recent record first
so this is the basic template for a type
1 dimension table writing the
latest version of the record to the
destination table could see it's making
use of bigquery's array AG functions
ordering by that order by clause we
generated and picking the most recent
record and that replaces the destination
table for type 2 dimension tables we
write the deep duplicated history and we
add history fields of effective start
and end time stamp of the record in a
third field which is a flag field
indicating whether this record is the
current record for this key so this is
making use of the windowing functions
that bigquery supports you can see we're
generating the three extra fields I
mentioned in getting and D duplicating
the records another problem way to solve
is having atomic isolated data sets for
their data flow jobs so we needed the
data process by data flow to be atomic
so that downstream jobs see just the
complete output or no output for data
flow job fields we don't want downstream
jobs to see partial data and it needs to
be isolated if two concurrent jobs are
running at the same time we don't want
them to be using the same file names and
and stepping on each other so GCS has
acid guarantees for individual file
objects but data flow runs in parallel
and produces the whole data set of
related files and we need these acid
guarantees for the whole data set so we
created GCSE data set standard and set
of libraries to support that standard
and it uses two locations on GCSE a data
set location and an index location and
the data flow job is configured to use
the data set location each job having a
unique ID
in the destination and when the dataflow
job completes successfully we write a
metadata JSON file that's to the index
location that has the logical name of
the datasets and our libraries are
written so that downstream jobs can read
the get the latest version of the
metadata and retrieves the data set from
the data set location another decision
we had to make is how to shard our fact
tables so our Big Data fact tables are
all partitioned by day but we also have
distinct subsets of data on an on time
field for instance for our Google
double-click add data we have the event
type such as impression click or video
conversion so some queries are only
interested in a subset of the event
types and we want to reduce our query
costs by scanning only the event type
rows needed by those queries so the
system we came up with was to load to
multiple tables that have the exact same
field schema one table for each event
type and we created views that union
alls these tables together so queries
can you know just query the data that
the need by choosing that the the views
that the query another decision way to
make is about time zones so our decision
was to use big queries timestamp type in
our physical tables so our
transformations all convert the
timestamps to UTC before loading into
those tables if users need to see data
in different time zones we create a view
the view generating extra time fields
under that specific time zone and
another problem we encountered during
our project was providing the bigquery
table schema during loads we didn't have
any problems when loading the fact
tables which is the first things that we
worked on
we wrote to the fact tables they were
partitioned by day as I explained so
we're loading in write truncate mode
replacing those daily partitions and we
didn't need to supply the table schema
on those loads because bigquery
preserves the schema for these partition
tables but then we got to the dimension
part of the project as I explained
earlier we're copying those dimension
tables once a day from our knife I
workflows and the dimension tables are
not partitioned so we're loading to
these unpartitioned tables also in write
truncate mode to overwrite the tables we
found that the table schema was not
preserved then so we just had to change
our jobs to provide the table schemas
for those jobs
next Pescara will discussed the tableau
migration and our overall
recommendations from the experience we
had with our migration project hello
again
I'll talk to you briefly about our
tableau migration process that we have
implemented so the first thing what we
did we took inventory of all the
Warburg's tables and reports that we
have to migrate and as you know for any
company were a period of time you will
create a lot of reports which would be
unused you know once you take about six
months or one year or many years so we
took time to identify those unused
Warburg's tables and everything and we
took them out of the migration process
and that help does with the migration
time as well we also took the priorities
from our stakeholders which is very
important and also the conversion was
done based on the priority given by the
stakeholders so that they understands in
a1 the tables are coming for them to
work with and the last thing is you know
getting the review and sign off by the
owners is also critical
next let us look at the conversion steps
of the tableau workbooks itself you know
as you can see this is like a I hope you
can see the picture well this is like an
assembly diagram so assembly line you
cleared a new data source with a
bigquery connection and then a rename
the columns same as existing data source
copy the calculated fields to the new
data source and replace the old data
source with new bigquery data source and
then the last step is validate so it's
like an assembly line now you repeat
this for each and every workbook and now
let us see some of the challenges that
we faced during the migration so for
tableau conversion what we did we have
migrated some stale data to cloud to
help with initial conversion we did this
mainly because we would like both the
migration and also tableau conversion go
in parallel so that we are not waiting
on one another at the same time you know
make the progress with a project with
the given time line that we have and but
because of that you know we had to
validate some of the reports twice but I
think that's ok we couldn't avoid it and
then as we are doing the migration you
know business is not going to stop
because they'll continuously create the
reports and it was a challenge for us to
keep up with all the new workbooks that
are being created and then bringing them
into the conversion pipeline and then
plan the conversion and that added some
timeline for us but you know it was a
challenge and we were able to mitigate
that and then if you look at converting
all these workbooks you know it took
some time for us to get a hang of it you
know what is the best way to migrate in
a quick way so it is like extract
convert convert the tableau wanna review
and then rinse repeat sign-off like it
is a assembly line as we talked before
so I'm sure now some of the users some
of you might be looking at
tablo migration so I would like to talk
to you about some of the tips about the
tableau migration that might be useful
for you based on what we thought so if
you are using custom sequels in tableau
conversions make sure to include the
workbook name as a comment as the first
line of the sequel and this will help
you a lot
in identifying any sequels that you
would like to tune further and identify
now what is the workbook name and
everything and one way to identify is
good going through the audit logs if you
go through the audit logs you can only
look at the sequence that are running
but not the workbook names so that is
the way you can get the workbook name
pardon me David
for saying this I hope you're okay to
say ok with me saying this a big no-no
for you know using select star on any of
your largest tables you will get to know
it pretty quickly once you start using
bigquery and that is so especially
because if you are coming from a
traditional relational database because
that is how we got to know because the
costs are going to be pretty high if you
are using select star on large tables
because the data the cost is based on
the amount of data that you are scanning
in the query and there are some
standards that you have to follow for
tableau conversions you know for example
for column aliases you have to use only
letters numbers and underscore then it
should start with a letter or underscore
only and the date format that bigquery
except is you know in a specific format
yyy mmdd and now I would like to show
you some of the experiences from these
stakeholders you know what this said
about bigquery now that all the
migration is completed in their own
words I mean these are all self
explanatory and as you can see now they
thought that it is kind of a
self-service play
form because they were able to automate
the queries by themselves they were able
to create the summary tables you know
without asking for any help and also
they were able to share the queries
across the project Lupo which is a great
feature that they allowed it and then
you know bigquery they all the heavy
lifting was done using bigquery whereas
you know they were only looking at
smaller data sets when they're working
with Python notebooks
there's also another great feature and
also it's a significantly faster
processing you know according to what
the stakeholders have said and they were
able to work with the truly big data
because in the past when they were
running atomic queries sometimes it is
taking forever in some of the databases
but now they're all getting the data in
a very very reasonable time in some
cases you know within a few seconds and
minutes now which is great and also
another thing what we did we empower the
stakeholders in some cases we give the
ownership of the projects to some of
these take key stakeholders that help
them to be self-sufficient and what they
would like to do and they're very pretty
happy with it and also their team was
able to do a lot of things you know
without getting any help from other
central teams and also as we discussed
before you know we migrated the atomic
data wherein we introduced on the error
fields and then these error functions
actually helped us with you know in
improving the performance on the queries
and also reducing the cost on the
queries that we are running on the
atomic data and also it has simplified
the code from few pages to few lines of
code this is a great feature and if you
are having any large data sets and if
you can introduce these functionality
please do so and also another
interesting feature that the customers
have liked was in
creation of Google sheets with bigquery
and this one was definitely liked by
some of the stakeholders in our company
now let us look at some of the big ones
for us you know what are the big wins
that we have seen as you have seen in
the previous slides happy stakeholders
what else we need you know that's all
what we are all striving for we want to
make the customers happy and that's what
happened with the bigquery migration and
significant improvement with SLS and we
have seen a lot of improvement and also
for Super Bowl 53 just a couple of
months ago we were able to process the
largest data sets during that event
without any problem without any
limitations on the database sizes which
is great and our operations team they
were able to reduce the footprint of the
data center because we were able to shut
down Tara data in a loop and then our
engineers are able to focus on the real
problems rather than you know some other
day-to-day issues that we have been
seeing with on-premise infrastructure
and also we were able to reduce the
number of tables from on-premise to
cloud we were able to reduce a thing at
least about 50% of the tables we were
able to eliminate because as I said
before you know or a period of time you
create the tables and we never use them
because the functionality have changed
or the project got dumped out and nobody
is using it and we never know that so
you we took time to identify those
tables and then remove them from the
migration and reduce the dependency is
increased productivity and that is what
we have seen with the cloud migration
because everybody was able to do a lot
of the tasks on their own with less
dependency on the central themes now
that we are coming to the end you know I
would like you to leave with some of the
takeaways that we learned from this
magnesian probably they would be useful
for you if you are planning of migrating
data to the cloud training training
training and and don't get us wrong you
know we did trying our engineers
but at the end when we did the you know
retrospective of the project you know we
thought that we could do much more
training for our engineers and also if
you are working in a small team make
sure to cross train your engineers
across different products and that will
help a lot and also if you can train on
your own company data rather than using
superstore data because the analyst will
get early on hands-on experience with
your own data and since you know you're
migrating at a new platform new software
new processes make sure you have that
feedback loop to identify you know the
improvements that you need to make on
the new processes that you are
implementing because sometimes I know we
ignore that but I think that is what we
have seen is always good to have that
feedback and the task force so this is
something that worked very very well for
us because they're invested into the
process in the process and they have
been working with us and we are working
with them all along throughout the
migration to make any major decisions
around them cloud migration and they're
happy to be part of it and it helped
them to know how things are changing and
how they should be prepared and also it
helped them to get early access to the
data and also help identifying the
issues early on and then it time to
discover and retire any obsolete
processes or tables even though
sometimes it is Tomkins time-consuming
because it took some time for us to go
through all the logs and everything but
it will help you in the migration time
and the overall process so that you can
remove the clutter in the new platform
the next one is try to migrate most
recent data to the cloud first in our
case what would that is what we did and
he it helped the analyst to you early
access to the data and also they were
able to play with our own data in the
cloud and
help us to give us the feedback on
identifying the problems early on that
is a great thing that helped us and when
we did that we also copied the dimension
data to the cloud so that they can get
the entire data set how to play with
query cost this is very very important
and even now we know we have been seeing
some of the areas where we can improve
in our in our company but what we did
especially with our cloud migration we
have created some alerts early on to
alert us if any query if anybody is
running a query that cost the cost is
exceeding certain limit we'll get an
email or alert so it's like a training
the users to tell them hey you know this
is the query you ran and this query cost
a few thousand dollars and so please be
mindful because you know we had queries
in aware initially when we started
working with bigquery there were users
are now who round the queries worth
$8,000 you may not believe it but that
is true but pretty quickly you know we
were able to you know contain that and
then everybody now is you know able to
run the queries very effectively and
those alerts helped us and even we are
continuously improving on how well you
know we can improve the process and also
our strategy with go-live is a
sequential and that how does a lot
because it gave us momentum you know
once we go live with first business unit
it give us a momentum for the rest of
the groups and had to go alive because
they have seen other people other
business units going live and that
helped you know us and also them so
there's what I would suggest you know if
you have many many brands that's what I
think you can take that approach and as
you have seen oh this is a very very
complex project or many many brands with
a lot of different priorities and we
have a great team and excellent
stakeholders and that is how we were
able to do it and
that's all what we have and thank you
for joining our session today
[Music]